okay that's true who are the worst dads
in anime oh that's [__] go man uh
Shinji shinji's dad gendo that's the
yeah
what about the just like just
confidently that bad like I just hate my
kid that much like that's almost
impressive that he committed that hard
to it he was only one step away from you
know looking at Shinji being like who
like like I would say he he committed so
much to being a bad dad that he was
always around which is more than some
other bad dads right which I think is
it's kind of gaslighting Shinji right
it's like no I'm near you but we're
getting there get in the robot I mean
the other the other uh the other
stereotypical bad dad is uh Nina's dad
from formula Alchemist obviously I know
I know what you're talking about yeah I
don't know whatever his name I'm trying
to think of some Devil's Advocate where
I can I could argue he's a good dad
I would love to hear this the AI would
be great to hear me out here okay okay
so
um
let me let me break it down for you okay
let me break it down for you is there
anything more pure in life than a dog
he wanted her to be a good boy forever
yeah
how do you keep children pure and
innocent forever okay you cross them
with a dog okay that's I I have not seen
Fullmetal Alchemist but I'm guessing
that was his motivation and you know
what I kind of dig with it man you know
what you know what daughters overrated
dogs though look that [__] sticks with
you look I bet that daughter would have
grown up to be a [__] to be a [__]
Turd Man okay every daughter reaches
that age in in that teenage hood you
know when they're just like Dad I don't
care about you stinky get the
he was just like oh you're about to hit
puberty not on my watch
um I asked it to why is Nina's dad from
Fullmetal Alchemist right and he goes
the series does not depict any character
of the perspective of right or wrong
yeah that should have consequences and
they make mistakes as well the story
doesn't shy away from showing characters
flaws
I mean that's an interesting defense
that's an interesting defection yeah
like I'm with God in this Camp he just
wanted to make a good boy yeah fair
enough and was the dog a little sad yeah
but that those could be sad we just
don't hear them you know it's a work in
progress I think imagine if he actually
perfected though and the dog is happy
when it happens then I think science
maybe yeah exactly maybe he's the
uncomfortable questions
maybe he's the victim maybe he was like
I just wanted to make a good boy and
then it ended up being a sad dog he was
a scientist helping us yeah this was his
first attempt at it you know and you
know every scientific breakthrough has a
few failures every now and again you
know are we gonna say no to human
experimentation just because a few
people have violently murdered I don't
know I don't know he's just like all
right
it's like wife I need another daughter
we need another one this experiment went
wrong don't don't ask I'm really
actually now the lack of dads in anime
there's not a lot there's a lot of good
Dads Mecca definitely does not have a
good track record there's somebody Just
Dance aren't around I mean just just I
mean like like think about it
perspective right it's just like what
every every Mecca dad just wants to
[__] take over the world be a shitty
dad well think about it even in like you
know in the defense of like gendo for
instance like he was a good dad to Ray
he was a [__] tab to Shinji though I
would argue he was a good husband
already oh yeah yeah Dad slash husband
it all goes back I can't think of any
other dads I'm just afraid I'm looking
around I okay if we're not if there's so
many people if we're not talking about
anime specifically or like I guess
things that came from and to anime like
say if like Pokemon right the Pokemon
series I never see Ash's dad I I got one
right what about rudius's dad from
Ashoka tense though
with uh when he gets reincarnated yeah
yeah the one week
I like him he's got he's he's like that
floor a little Playboy yes a little
Playboy yeah I like it I think he's a
good dad I think he's he's one of the
most human dads I've seen he's a bit of
a scumbag but yeah he also is a good dad
so it makes him a lot more believable as
a character he like tries to be a good
dad like I think the scene that got me
in michokotensei uh was the scene where
rudius like hugs him to be like I wasn't
the perfect dad and he's just like I
forgive you I was like oh [__] man I
wish I could tell my dad that sometimes
okay okay question ask a lad uh racing
well I'll tell you about his son but
basically yeah yeah yeah it's just like
the same time yeah yeah he's the best
stepdad yeah
kills your real dad yeah and then
becomes the goat dad like like obviously
killing the real dad is bad but if he
becomes an even better Dad I think
there's a there's a question to be but
he went he went into it he went into him
an alpha mentality he was like I'm gonna
kill your real dad because I'm more
confident I could be a better dad than
your real dad that's why he's the ugly
but good Dad yeah yeah okay
so you know he's the best Welsh dad
we've had yet okay
yes is Minato a good dad to Naruto
is Naruto a good dad is Naruto a good
dad as well double question Naruto
narut neither Naruto or Sasuke are good
dads [__] like obviously Sasuke isn't
honestly ever want to be have a kids
anyway Sasuke went out to get milk and
never came back he was that he was that
Dad man I feel so sorry for what was her
name like sarada yeah
you know you're a bad dad because you
name your daughter [__] sour Sasuke's
the kind of dude who felt like he would
try and explain to you for 10 minutes
why he took the condom off right before
he put it in you know what I mean like
he would have he would have a full-on
conversation trying to justify it to you
yeah that's the vibe he gives off yeah
the only the only part of boruto I've
seen is for like the new narrator movie
so I'm not like up to date yeah to like
boruto so I don't know how good of a dad
narrative is now but my [__] god he
needs to learn how to discipline his kid
man [__] me man he's out of [__]
control he is man Bros is a dick you
know it's so weird because like see I I
forget that boruto is not even an only
child but everyone forgets like he has a
sister because her sisters her sister is
so well behaved right and Naruto is
definitely that Dad was that was just
like I was a [__] [__] when I was
a kid so you know what kid you can be a
[__] too and I'm like no Naruto
don't do that my dad wasn't there during
my childhood I won't be for yours either
I'm learning by example you think you'd
think from not having like not not
growing up with parents that narrator
would want to like offset that and be a
really good [__] parent and be there
for his kid he does he doesn't learn
from that you think he would know that I
guess anime normally has father figures
as opposed to fathers yeah straight up I
don't know I guess
I guess choose your own dad I guess
that's it yeah and that was that was the
anime dads The Good The Bad and The Ugly